Can computers read our brains and know what
we’re seeing?
They’re now a small step closer.
Researchers at Purdue University are using
artificial neural networks,
to decode real neural networks.
They scanned three women’s brains as they
watched videos
and recorded brain activity in response to
each clip.
An AI algorithm successfully learned to predict
how their brains would respond to new clips.
Another algorithm learned to look at their
brains and predict what they saw.
The reconstructed images looked like fuzzy ghosts.
But the AI could at least guess the category
of the content: birds, faces, and so on.
The researchers are using Artificial Intelligence
to understand the brain,  in order to further improve AI.
Brainy, huh?